bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo
video sono fa dj oggi stiamo su ciò
mentre i dati della verità ragazzi io so
che siete tutti emozionati per questo
bellissimo gioco anche lui lo sa
comunque ragazzi nello scorso episodio
giocato a ai miei livelli quindi i
livelli fari jb geometri nascere ma no
io ho visti tutti quindi volevo provare
a vedere se ce n'erano altri se schiatti
poi che cazzo ne so che hpv è giusto per
capire se c'è c'è cacchio cacchio buddha
di voto lino tordino prova a fare voglio
provare vedere se riesco a giocare a
kakà pupù solo per vedere che cos'è
ecco una merda lo diceva il nome che era
una merda
questa vasta rosa ma non puoi fa è
impossibile come cazzo faccio a salire
sul talento sì se ciò fa aveva sono un
gene ragazzi ho vinto non sono io
chiamavo tinto calca futuro incluso che
i ragazzi perché perché me lo merito
come solito ragazzi servito è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace eravamo
rimossi a questo qua che era
difficilissimo prof.re quello dopo che
non ancora provato da gionata ascoltami
jonathan io sono tuo amico però o gesù
cristo e la madonna che sullo sfondo
stranissimo mio dio mi chiama non riesco
a fare un passo cioè una roba imposti ok
si ok perfetto e l'ho fatto si è partiti
ragazzi di pezzenti di merate calmi
calmi bene dove cazzo sarda che canzone
è questa è lenta e tranquillo di solito
calcio alla dubstep quella è lentissima
oh mio dio ricaccia faccio la faccio
c'era un coso con mancato abbia pazienza
dove vado
ma io sto vince sono ancora con la
supposta la dovrei avere ancora la
supposta suo nome doveva entrare nel
cerchio dovevo togliermi la sono tolta
lo stesso
cos'è un mio dio che cazzo ragazzi è la
madonna seriamente qualcuno mi spiega
che cosa è successo perché non ho capito
dal centro nei cerchi perché non la
prendono il cap ranzi ok
e vabbè pazienza si fa vivo no no è
certi puzza la mamma dai regala come ho
fatto a morire li mortacci tua 93 per
cento merda no no no no no no non è un
ragazzo viper ragazzi ho sbagliato e
sono uno stronzo in europa inguardabile
poi lo sfondo katyn trippa malissimo si
è fatta volta ciò fa ok ho vinto ho
vinto bene basta concludono veramente è
stato indecente 38 tentativi per sta
roba abbiate pazienza mi suicido prima
mi sento preso per il culo ogni volta
che si mettiamoci qualcos'altro che è un
dardo ciò fatta bene così ragazzi primo
primo tentativo non ne voglio sapere
primo tentativo e finisco facciamo un
secondo ragazzo faccia faccio cavi
canzesi tranquillo io sto diventando
esperto di questo paolino ti meriti di
vivere però sono tue faccio questo l'udc
sik sik sell on next nonché del nome che
c'hai ok ragazzi e bellissimo stato
faccia lo scivolo fa tutto lui
cioè io posso stare anche fermo nel
primo punto no non proprio fare
seriamente a parte ok ma che è tipo
raggio e se un giornate forest rega è
minecraft erano viste sugli alberi moio
[ __ ] che ne so ma mica mi sembra a
me sembravano alberi tranquilli vai via
uccido il fratello avete preso sto vizio
di mettere sto sfondo che mi in trip al
cervello e non capisco più niente
ok ok e questo è bello lungo mista di
livello regalo perfetto che cazzo
successo la madonna è ma non ce l'ho
fatta a caso a caso una sega ragazzo a
livello il più incasinato che abbia mai
fatto ma ma ma ma ma fa comunque schifo
così è impossibile da fare abbiate
pazienza che non si può
sì sì sì già fatta arriva il proprio che
ha preparato uno morto prima che
arrivasse il drop c'è ma si può ma mori
ci arriviamo al troppo almeno è figo
ragazzi e bellissimo no seriamente dove
vado dove cazzo io se muoio non ce la
farò mai più a tornare qua sappiatelo
merda devo concentrarmi ragazze spese
radio eh va beh ragazzi stavolta mi
carica un casino però è bellissima solo
questa pro ok dov'è che sono molto prima
che mi dico ok air da ragazzino annuncia
farò mai lo so già invece invece un
cazzo dai forza si no non saltare merda
devo saltare maledizione ma come si fa a
fare un livello del genere è una roba
inguardabile salta sì sì sì sì sì che
cazzo non ho capito manco io che cos'è
ma aveva perché ti prego ti prego ti
prego ti prego ti prego ti prego sì sì
che cos'è questa roba di preciso ragazzi
ho toccato gli alberi però toccato
questa merda che il simbolo di the sims
forza viviamo andiamo andiamo andiamo
andiamo fieri di merda sì ce frega sì ci
ho fatta natale è finito per che cazzo
c'è ancora la stella la soprano chiedo
veramente come sia possibile aver fatto
una roba del è assurdo
c'è ma quello che ha fatto poi ci apra
rigiocato l'avrà finito per vedere se
funzionava come cazzola finito e quello
che mi chiedo è impossibile però già già
sa farti arrivare qua impossibile non
sono che come ho fatto io però dopo
diventa ancora più assurdo cioè
indecente bene bravissimo madonna quanta
roba
tanta roba tanta roba
maledette stelle vede il filo super iv
ok bene piano piano piano cosa faccio
adesso
ragazzi non sono al contrario tra
sta piovendo come sta piovendo cosa 12
ore di gioco si ferma su 69 coincidenza
io non credo ma [ __ ] ragazzi non
ce la faccio piu sono quattro ore e
mezza che sta andando avanti sullo
stesso livello a me ne fotto se a 69 per
cento si è fermato io comunque prometto
che ha xixe techland sonics chiunque tu
sia ad avere questo bellissimo nome che
sicuramente un nuovo e più bello della
tua faccia dopo che abbiamo preso a
testate ti prometto che ti prenderò
testate se livello era un amanda cosa
bellissima però non si poteva fare nella
vita quindi prova un altro perché non è
possibile
ecco è questo che cazzo sarebbe mi fate
fare due mete la cosa ma comunque
ragazzi quello di prima è assolutamente
il livello più difficile della storia di
geometri da jean è questa oggi cielo
ragazzi che secondo me guarda che ho una
sega un compenso giuro che i ragazzi
geometri da chi mi sta facendo uscire
pazzo non ci posso credere orcadi quella
[ __ ] porca non c'è bei versi è
attorcigliato al mouse mara che emerga
la rai non ci posso che io veramente
stento a crederci che assurdo
ho tenuto premuto la causa ma serio se
bastava tener premuto sta merda se io
tenevo premuto prima ce la facevo fino
al 71 per cento ma veramente cioè che
cazzo giocato a fare allora non so che
cosa devo fare di precise sì sì no no
non ci credo oggi ho vinto ho vinto dove
ho vinto che sono morto
ho vinto non importa va bene sono
partito per nettuno però sono ho vinto
uguali a me l'ha dato uguale per me va
benissimo ragazzi sono contento perfetto
vabbè basta basta basta
ragazzi non ce la posso più fare
comunque chi ha fatto quel livello che
mi sono fermato a 69 per cento deve
essere torturato male anche ragazzi dire
che anche per oggi posso chiudere qui
con geometri di share
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto a
parte col livello che sono sicuro che è
seminato una mano andiamo a cercare chi
l'ha fatto e li facciamo male anche
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto la 7a
sottomento vi piace anche a fasce di
facebook e corna divido la prescrizione
sono se dovessi discreti ai civili belle
ragazze